Carter and Faye are with us in Tucson
Arizona
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show guys how
are you well how you doing Dave better
than I deserve I see on my screen you
guys are debt-free
yes we are I love it I love it how much
have you paid off about a hundred
thousand dollars whoa how long did that
take four years and nine months okay and
making what kind of money during that
time range from one hundred ninety
thousand to two hundred and fifty five
thousand well you make great money what
do you guys do I'm a family physician oh
okay
there it is all right and what kind of
debt was their student loans no we had
that taken care of but I I went into
some debt to buy some land hoping to
build a an office building on it turned
out that didn't happen we still own the
land but we got that paid off and then
the other probably close to a half was
was her home so we paid that off in
September oh that's fun paid for house
paid for dirt everything's paid for
everything how old are you guys 53 well
congratulations how's it feel to not
have any payments amazing can't can
describe it just so peaceful very I
don't just a huge weight that's off
taken off her shoulders well you and I
both know that Doc's have a horrendous
reputation with handling money and yet
you've done a fabulous job
congratulations
tell me your story what happened four
years and nine months ago that puts you
on this journey I was in a church
meeting and someone mentioned Dave
Ramsey I hadn't heard of you and so I
started listening to you looked you up
on the internet and found a class in
Tucson it I think it was Penta no
Christian Church that Faye and I went to
and we got rolling and we had our that
land loan paid off within a few months
and then liked us so much my my brother
who is my partner is he teases me about
being a Dave Ramsey disciple and so we
and I put on the class for our employees
we have about 15 employees and
spouses wanted to come they could as
well so we closed the building down for
13 weeks at that time for two hours so
that we could do that and help them and
some of them are are making good
progress as well that's very neat what's
the best story among the employees
what's the coolest thing that's happened
as a result of you guys paying for that
in doing that well I just had someone
the other day tell me that they got two
other student loans paid off and and
when they get the the paid off in full
notice they're gonna put it up on the
refrigerator I love it that's been huge
but counts I like it cuz they're nerds
right people are a horse man I'm telling
you you get those things off your back
you got you know that's that's a monkey
on the back right there well cool
congratulations great employer pouring
into your people like that thank you
very well done well thank you guys so
what was the hardest part of this for
you Fanny as you guys went through this
change well we got a son that died he
absolutely committed suicide oh my lord
how long ago was that that was January
of 14 okay 20 minutes ago still got your
breath away to talk about it I guess
yeah it's it's it's still still kind of
raw but you know it set us back for
awhile you've got off track and and but
we're now on and get get some traction
again yeah you get off track on
everything that would just blow your
world up man that's unbelievable how old
was he he was 21 oh my goodness
oh my goodness I'm so sorry thank you so
you guys are trucking along getting out
of debt and then that horrible tragedy
occurs right in the middle and then you
have to kind of get refocused back on
your life after that then I guess yeah
yeah I mean just some of the basics
eating and sleeping there yeah you know
just you know just fatigue and and you
know trying to trying to maintain you
know going back to work after a couple
weeks and things like that so yeah
was it took us several months to get get
back going again we're still trying to
refocus well that's a scar that will
never completely heal that parents are
not supposed to endure that that's awful
I'm so sorry
well thank you and in the middle of that
you know at least you clear off these
things and don't have this burden that's
nowhere near the same on the same scale
obviously but Wow Wow
I'm so sorry right thank you
so what is you guys message because I
mean out of that you I mean you went
back after that to paying off that I so
once you kind of got back on track you
finished off is that what you're saying
yes we had the the land already paid off
and we you know we continue to just make
our regular payments on the home we have
that set up you know automatically and
then about the middle of last year we we
started seeing oh if I can if we can
ramp it up and and start throwing some
more at the house we can get this paid
off by the end of the year and and so
that's that's what we did gives you
something to focus on them as your as
you find their way back up onto the road
kind of well yeah we actually we thought
about selling the house because of you
know he took his life here at or here at
home and but we decided that you know
this is our home and we decided to to
stay here and and try to make the best
of it I mean there's not going to be any
home that's going to be perfect without
you know without him here but we still
have three other children and we have
grandchildren and we have faith in God
things are things are gonna work out
okay and I'll just continue to move
forward the best we can yeah well we all
live with a broken heart of one kind or
another some are just more broken than
been through more horrible things than
others I'm so sorry for you guys I'm
happy for you that you've got that paid
for and then you got this little burden
of debt off of you while you guys are
faced this though oh my goodness thank
you yeah it has it has helped some with
kind of the healing and like you say one
merton so yeah and if you gives you
something to aim out while you're paying
it off as a goal to take your mind off
of other stuff a little bit well you
know and there's a certain amount to
that you know I got exercise and you
know do something just just distract
from the pain so yeah probably focusing
on this probably help with the healing
also yeah Wow well thank you for calling
in and sharing your story so openly it's
because other people are hearing this
obviously and there's some other folks
out there facing similar things and they
just need to hear I guess then I guess
you always just we all need to hear you
live through it don't you in the sense
of yeah you get on the other side it
doesn't it doesn't feel like you're
going to because it hurts so bad but but
but you do you do and yeah your faith
and and and you know blooming at goals
and so forth yeah that's real well all
right Carter and Faye Tucson Arizona
you got still with me yes we are okay I
thought I heard something hang up on
make sure I didn't lose you plays on the
speakerphone and I just turned in that
went off and I'm going to yell on my
phone got it okay Carter and Faye Tucson
Arizona $100,000 paid off in four years
and nine months making a hundred to 255
that's their house their land and
everything counted down let's hear a
debt free scream
well got you guys well done
man I can't breathe just talking to them
I can't imagine going through that you
know why most people don't win they
don't bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express gonna call my house and ask my
wife why she would stay with a man they
won't pay his bills